la suisse peut-elle aider julian assange
c'est en tout cas la volonté du canton
de genève il ya quelques jours le
parlement cantonal a adopté à une large
majorité une résolution dans ce sens
objectif délivrer un visa humanitaire à
julian assange
une requête pour laquelle il reste
encore un obstacle à franchir obtenir
l'approbation du gouvernement
un visa humanitaire ce n'est pas une
demande d'asile c'est de permettre à
quelqu'un de se faire soigner dans un
hôpital sécurisé
thurella 100g malade après dix ans de
torture c'est ce que dit le rapporteur
de l'onu sur la torture et c'est normal
qu'ils puissent avoir le temps se faire
soigner pour recouvrer sa santé et pour
pouvoir décider où elle ce qu'il veut il
souhait ce qu'il veut aller où est ce qu
il veut demander l'asile ou même rester
immédiatement après la résolution de
jean routhiau largement approuvée par le
canton de genève pour demander au
gouvernement suisse l'octroi d'un visa
humanitaire et des discussions se sont
tenues au parlement autrichien
ce parlement a offert son soutien à
julian contre l'extradition est donc il
y a des choses qui bougent
le canton de genève a brisé la glace et
nous espérons que d'autres cantons et
d'autres pays suivront la même voix off
des spots